[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to UT live I'm Sophie
Scholl ac joining me today is Trent
Harmon being here we've got the og the
last og American Idol in the house
congratulations on the new album thank
you so much
how are you feeling this week feeling
really good it's really really it's been
a special weekend got to debut the album
at the Opry I should have mentioned that
a second ago the Grand Ole Opry Friday
night how cool is that kind of cool kind
of cherry on top of everything you know
yeah bucket list moment right did you
freak out being in that circle a little
bit you know because I've come so full
circle like I used to just you know I
didn't have any songs at first I saying
cover songs songs I did an idol and now
I'm singing my songs off my album yeah
it was a cool moment that's so special
now be sure to send in your fan
questions you guys I'm gonna get to as
many of them as I possibly can and also
stick with us till the end of the
interview we are gonna have an exclusive
behind the scenes look at Trent's you
got them all music video it's really
cool I got to preview some of it it's
really cool to BTS yeah talk to me about
that day on set um any day on set for a
music video it's gonna be long I mean I
think I got to sit for 4:30 a.m. and we
wrapped like at nine o'clock that night
but we kept it all in Nashville all of
them all of my scenes I shot it pretty
close to where I live we shot some on
Broadway and it's a very beautiful video
far as just physically it's nice to look
at yeah yeah okay so the timing of this
album could not have been better with
Idol back on the air pretty good time in
there yeah I know is that bland I don't
well bad I don't know if it was planned
or not but I mean after two years of
waiting on an album I don't know if
anything is planned you know because
we've been I've been telling folks yeah
album's coming out soon I didn't have
any good songs really no I didn't have
any great songs that I felt comfortable
putting out to to fans and so I spent
the last two years writing the album
which makes it even more special yeah
absolutely I think that's great too that
they gave you the freedom to write your
own songs on your debut because a lot of
labels won't necessarily do that there's
a lot of trust and I had to turn in some
good songs up front
they go right for a little bit turn it
in and if it's good enough we'll give
you more rope and more rope you know and
yeah so I wrote you got them all which
is the title of the album and the title
of the single and it's really special
it's even more special because I wrote a
to the songs on the record yeah
absolutely and I love that your song
fallin is on there which was your
coronation song is that what it's called
yeah the last song you sing when you win
right right and that one was co-written
by Keith Urban working in Nashville
living in Nashville now do you ever see
Keith around no neither one of us are in
Nashville a lot oh if he's if he's on
ten times the schedule I'm on I'm sure
he is we're never in Nashville well tell
me about going back to Idol
it's obviously a revamped version it's a
little bit different what was the vibe
like when you were there it was it's
it's different but a lot of the same
crews there that I met so it was kind of
like high school reunion a little bit
but you know I really just wanted to get
a little face time with the contestants
that have already been cut the top five
is who was there and then it was three
before I left and I told them I said I
don't have a lot of words of advice for
you nobody had any from me
really I mean what do you tell somebody
what do you tell them go do your best
everybody knows you can sing what I told
them was this is all gonna be over in a
week it's all gonna be over whether you
win or lose you need to have a plan for
the morning after the show right every
song idea that comes into your head as a
potential cut on your record that you're
gonna put out one day that conversations
coming so be ready the day after the
show whether you win or lose mm-hmm and
be ready for a difficult road right it's
I mean you don't just if I said if you
end up in Nashville you're not just
gonna walk into a publishing house and
say hey here's my trophy please give me
some songs and play them right it
doesn't work like that you know but I
couldn't tell them that I just told them
have a plan for the day after the show
is over but I mean it's worth noting
that American Idol does have a great
track record of course comes to
launching talent so that's that's
hopeful to have American Idol in your
back pocket I know it's it's absolutely
helpful you know it'll help you to a
certain extent but at some point you're
gonna have to take a pen and a piece of
paper and write a song idea down and put
that out into the world and I wasn't
necessarily worried about that the
that I won the show you know and I wish
looking back that I would have been on
top of it just a little sooner I took
like a week not long but like a week you
know to figure it out and just wrap your
head around everything and I could have
been writing down some you know
inspiring thoughts in that week you know
and I I don't think that I did write
anything down so I really got on top of
it after that week yeah yeah and what
was it like backstage did you what would
you talk about with Ryan and like Katie
and Luke same old stuff funny the stuff
you talk about before you walk on live
TV yeah still doing music yeah still
hosting stuff yeah yeah but it felt like
a high school reunion it really did yeah
but I couldn't get voted off this time
so that's good a little less pressure
and on the album now you also did your
version of Sia's chandelier yeah so I do
my own shows of course now quite often
and I still have people screaming from
the crowd please do chandelier and quite
honestly the truth is I can't sing that
song every night it was hard it is very
very very tat like it's it's very very
hard on the vocals to do that every
night especially for a male I supposed
to be seeing stuff like that but I put I
listen to the people and I asked him
what song from Idol do you want on the
record and by and large they said
chandelier so listen to the people give
them what they want how did they come
together on the show was that your idea
to sing that song it was it was why did
you choose it at the time nobody wanted
wanted nobody expected me to pick that
song it just I mean it's not a
traditionally male song song I you know
and and I thought that it would be a
moment if I nailed it and I guess I did
it was a moment yeah and now it's on the
record now it's on the record that's
exciting
okay so I want to know what your next
single is gonna be because I have some
thoughts you and a lot of people want to
know what the next single yeah I don't
know I don't even know if I've written
it you know really I'm still writing I
write every week you know I still take
my co-writes and I take them really
seriously but yeah no single right now
okay well I want it to be five minutes
first five minutes you like that so I
love that song I've tweeted about that
song that song we actually don't play it
live a whole lot you know it's so good I
wanted people to hear the record version
first before they
compared and contrasted between the two
and so once they heard the record it's
gotten a lot of buzz that particular
song it sounds hooky it sounds like a
single it does I can hear it on race
sounds like you can hear it on radio
yeah absolutely
thank you is what I meant to say welcome
totally true and my other vote would be
money's on you know that's a special one
arguably the most most most dearest song
to my heart because I wrote that from my
grandmother's yeah you know a lot of
folks especially in the country format
write songs for people that inspired
them throughout their life after they
pass you know just which is great yeah I
wanted my grandmothers to have us all
along my debut album while they could
still go to the store and buy it yeah
that's so sweet how'd they react oh they
loved it this is really good one of them
was in the crowd Friday night when I
debuted at the record at the Opry and so
you can see it and I'll say my
grandmother's standing side-stage
money's on you this song is for you
grandma on special moment you know
that's amazing
now talk to me about the album as a
whole it's it's you know country but I
feel like when I listen to it there's a
lot of pop influence there's even some
like soul in there a lot of other stuff
so how would you kind of describe it um
I don't really I don't really buy into
geometers yeah you listen to me talking
no I'm country but I don't just sing
country I didn't I think that was a big
benefit of me winning Idol was that I
didn't necessarily have to take stand by
me and sing it with a steel guitar just
because I'm a country artist understand
by me would do it like it was written
you know we'll do it with a pop soul
vibe and so that came through in the
music part but the lyric the lyrics of
these songs are country and it's special
even more so because I got to write
eight of the eleven I knew that it would
be special I knew the debut album would
be a big deal but since it's my songs
for the majority of it it's even more
special it's my language it's how I talk
in the record you know that now one last
question before we get to the clip are
you still in touch with LA Porsha or
anybody else from your season a few
people yeah if there's busy as I am they
don't have time
catchup you know but we also follow each
other and socials and we retweet all of
our things you know but you know it was
kind of one of those cool heists I've
mentioned high school again but it was
kind of where those moments where
everybody's here and we're having a
great time but once we all go our
separate ways
it's each man to his own respect and go
do your work and go make it and I think
we'll all catch up one day probably at
Joan's on third or something and get
something to eat yeah that was our
hanging was it was our hang oh so you
got to be visiting it while you're here
then right I tried to last night I
forgot Joan's you close at eight o'clock
you're killing so I got there like at
7:55 yeah you gotta go today you got
time settle for sugar fish you know what
you can't go wrong oh my god I miss
sugar enjoy it on my behalf thank you
for being your truck so good to see you
thank you guys for watching before we
leave stay tuned for this special
exclusive behind-the-scenes clip of
Trent's new music video you got them all
thanks for watching
[Music]
those west coast lights she talked about
in his sleep things you always thought
that I could be okay so we just wrapped
the first scene opening scene for the
music video for you got them all we're
moving to the second look here we go
[Music]
the girlfriend called and said that she
would be moving to Thailand kind of hit
pretty heavy I wrote this song just a
couple days after she left of a place of
fear you know I didn't know if she would
come back I didn't know if when she got
back what our status would be so yeah I
wrote that for this song from that place
it's a very special song to me because
it's true because I feel better and I
think you get okay
[Music]
James's treatment caught my eye because
it was the closest to the lyric I could
actually read through the song while I
was reading his treatment and it showed
him you know two characters living their
lives simultaneously but with a split
screen so ones here and ones there
that's literally what was going on in my
life
[Music]
she's gonna be walking on the beach at
one point and he'll be in the city and
it'll look you know they'll both reach
out and look like they're holding hands
and it's gonna just roll like that
through the whole thing you'll kind of
see her through her struggles that she's
trying to achieve her dream and you'll
see the connection between the two
different players between him and her
the whole time
we're at Westside ballet school and
we're filming the ballet scene
I'm putting on my shoes and stretching
and the shot
pursue my dream
professional ballet dancer
[Music]
going by his treatment I kind of feel
like we're on the same page as far as
where the lyric the song the performance
so far we've all hit all those on the
head it's been a pleasure working with
him so far
real easy really easy Hank we are about
to do last looks got our last shot right
here we're looking right over a river
it's gonna be a 360 performance about to
wrap it up girl I'm still waiting no
life to beginning key and steal ain't no
need to give a second chance to stop me
and steal my breath
in every parking lot still to show
[Music]
yes I feel
[Applause]
and I think you get all that's a wrap
guys it's a good day everybody was
positive yeah I think it's gonna look at
it all right we got them all
oh there we go think about it Akemi yeah
that's a wrap
there we go oh girl I think you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]